[Musique]
bonsoir des enfants soins ce soir nous
venons vous dire au revoir car nous
partons pour notre nouveau voyage où
grosso c'est bien triste de vous quitter
moi aussi au sein où il pas trop mais
vous le savez nous reviendrons le plus
vite possible vous retrouver et nous
aurons des tas de belle histoire à vous
raconter alors je veux un patron oui
descend vite nounours et en bracelet
bien fort de ma part oui
la jemaye encore des mouchoirs et ma
poupée préférée
bonsoir les petits voyageurs sa mort
comment vous faites encore vos bagages
cette fois c'est fini on a tout préparé
pour notre départ de matt et vous
dénoncez vous n'avez rien oublié
d'importer paraguay oui oui oui qui
truste grosse faute si on viendra
bientôt tienne nous prend ça je prends
ton voyage est très gros pot de miel
mais ne mangent pas tous premiers gens
vont des enfants j'en mangerais d'une
seule cuillère chaque jour et comme
cette passerelle
oui c'est promis merci le cher petit ami
7 vous viendrez dans un mois chicago
vous n'oublierez pas d'emmener le petit
poussin avec vous oh non on m avec une
maman poule il aura bien chaud il
s'amusera avec d'autres pistes jarry
allons les enfants au dodo pullis
m'appelle ben ainslie
[Musique]
beaucoup bien gros jour tu sais on a
pris une belle chanson pour toi et pour
ulysse parce que nous vous aimons
beaucoup beaucoup
oui beaucoup comme ça moi c'est la fin
de la journée c'est maman de se coucher
[Musique]
amis mais il s'en va tout seul et nous y
allons aussi de ma guise
je n'en sais rien oh je l'entends dire
ni nous dira fermez vos yeux et dormait
tous les deux nous sommes bien dans nos
prix sauf nous souhaitons bonne amie
sagon ce mois le faire
un plaisir d'y voir mes deux petits amis
au revoir votre chanson est très belle
bon voyage à bientôt nounours un bientôt
les entrants bons
[Musique]
on
au revoir petit louis au revoir petite
mirabelle passer de belles vacances et
soyez bien gentil n'oubliez pas d'aller
vous coucher sagement chaque soir et
nous reviendrons bientôt vous voir
allons allons ne sois pas triste
nounours car les petits enfants savent
bien qu'on reviendra vite ils ne sont
pas tristes d'un corps patrons peuvent
j'aime beaucoup un subtil tout était en
ordre pour le voyage
oui patron tout alors en route roux au
revoir tous nos amis et à bientôt
bonne nuit
[Musique]
bonsoir les enfants ont joué ce soir
nous venons vous dire au revoir car nous
partons pour notre nouveau voyage ou
groso c'est bien triste de vous quitter
moi aussi au saut où il pas trop mais
vous le savez nous reviendrons le plus
vite possible vous retrouver et nous
aurons des tas de belle histoire à vous
raconter alors je veux un patron oui
descend vite nounours et en bracelet
bien fort de ma part oui
la jemaye encore des mouchoirs et ma
poupée préférée
bonsoir les petits voyageurs sa mort
comment vous faites encore vos bagages
cette fois c'est fini on a tout préparé
pour notre départ demain matin et vous
dénoncez vous n'avez rien oublié
d'importer paraguay oui oui oui
sept russes deux grosses fautes qui vous
viendra bientôt
tiens ne nous prend ça tu prends ton
voyage est très gros pot de miel mais ne
mangent pas tous premiers jo des enfants
j'en mangerais d'une seule cuillère
chaque jour et comme cette passerelle
oui c'est promis merci le cher petit ami
7 vous viendrez dans un mois
chicago vous n'oublierez pas d'emmener
le petit poussin avec vous oh non
un mètre avec une maman poule il aura
bien chaud il s'amusera avec d'autres
pistes j'avais alors les enfants au dodo
pullis m'appelle onemi
[Musique]
ou bien grosses joues tu sais on a pris
une belle chanson pour toi et pour le
lis pas ce que nous vous aimons beaucoup
beaucoup
oui beaucoup comme ça moi c'est la fin
de la journée c'est le moment de se
coucher la zone
à nous
amis ils s'en vont tous sont liés nous y
allons aussi de ma glycémie au jeu
l'entente qui lie
ni nous dira fermez vos yeux et demi
tous les deux nous sommes bien dans
notre ligue
sauf vous souhaite bonne amie sa grosse
mois
un plaisir avait dit au revoir mes deux
petits amis au revoir votre chanson est
très belle
bon voyage à bientôt 90 à bientôt les
enfants
[Musique]
au revoir petit louis au revoir petite
mirabelle passer de belles vacances et
soyez bien gentil n'oubliez pas d'aller
vous coucher sagement chaque soir et
nous reviendrons bientôt vous voir
allons allons ne sois pas triste
nounours car les petits enfants savent
bien qu'on reviendra vite ils ne sont
pas tristes d'un corps patron buzz
j'aime beaucoup un subtil tout était en
ordre pour le voyage
oui patron tout alors en route au revoir
tous nos amis et à bientôt
bonne nuit
[Musique]
bonsoir des enfants sourds ce soir nous
venons vous dire au revoir car nous
partons pour notre nouveau voyage groso
c'est bien triste de vous quitter
moi aussi au sein où il pas trop mais
vous le savez nous reviendrons le plus
vite possible vous retrouver et nous
aurons des tas de belle histoire à vous
raconter alors je veux un patron oui
descend vite nounours et en bracelet
bien fort de ma part oui
la jemaye encore des mouchoirs et ma
poupée préférée
bonsoir les petits voyageurs comment
vous faites encore vos bagages
cette fois c'est fini on a tout préparé
pour notre départ demain matin et vous
dénonce vous n'avez rien oublié
d'emporter paraguay oui oui oui
pétrus devons pas être ici on viendra
bientôt tienne nous prend ça tu perds
ton voyage est très gros pot de miel
mais ne mangent pas tous le premier
héros des enfants j'en mangerais d'une
seule cuillère chaque jour est une
passerelle
oui c'est promis merci le cher petit ami
7 vous reviendrai dans un mois chic à la
hausse
vous n'oublierez pas d'emmener le petit
poussin avec vous oh non un mètre avec
une maman poule n aura bien chaud et
s'amusera avec d'autres petits puissent
arborer patron jarry à l'eau les enfants
au dodo ulysse m'appelle ben ainslie
[Musique]
beaucoup de bien gros jour tu sais on a
pris une belle chanson pour toi et pour
ulysse parce que nous vous aimons
beaucoup beaucoup
oui beaucoup comme ça moi si la fin de
la journée c'est maman de se coucher
nous faisons maintenant
amis mila s'en vont tous sont liés nous
y allons aussi
[Musique]
mais qu'ils lisent je n'en sais rien
oh je l'entends dire
ni nous dira fermez vos yeux est
d'emmener tous les deux nous sommes bien
dans notre lit au software bonanni sa
grosse mois
un plaisir d'y voir mes deux petits amis
au revoir votre chanson est très belle
bon voyage à bientôt 90 à bientôt
les entrants bons
[Musique]
au revoir petit louis au revoir petite
mirabelle passer de belles vacances et
soyez bien gentil n'oubliez pas d'aller
vous coucher sagement chaque soir et
nous reviendrons bientôt vous voir
allons allons ne sois pas triste
nounours car les petits enfants savent
bien qu'on reviendra vite ils ne sont
pas tristes d'un corps patrons peuvent
j'aime beaucoup un subtil tout était en
ordre pour le voyage
oui patron tout alors en route au revoir
tous nos amis et à bientôt
bonne nuit
[Musique]
bonsoir
nous sommes très contents aujourd'hui
car gros ours est tout à fait guéri et
se sent très bien on vous dit pas trop
je me sens bien
la vie est belle je me sens léger au
lolobo je manquais tomber mais fais
attention nounours tu n'es plus un
papillon si tu tombes qui va te faire
très mal c'est vrai patron je ne suis
plus un papillon à l'on descend voir nos
deux petits amis ils t'attendent
sûrement avec impatience mais que fais
tu nounours je jette mon échelle ou au
pardon patron j'ai rien acheter du tout
que je suis distrait ce pauvre nounours
le printemps lui à tourner la tête aux
copeaux haut up
vive le joli mois de mai au port en eau
profonde qui lui tu sais bien que tu
dois faire tes gars car ils n'ont alors
gens comme un mur à bâle
elle file ça fera du bien bon cas
bonsoir mes enfants je les voyais ma
parole tue six ton pouce au petit louis
il a plus tard bros bon ben on ne sait
pas vrai j'en ai juste perdu quand tu
n'as pas dans mes propos et puis on peut
pas moi j'ai bon
j comme un putois l'eau à l'ombre
elle va vite repoussée 7 dans tous les
petits enfants changent de d'en haut et
où est-ce que tu l'a caché mais il faut
bien la cacher et quand la petite souris
la trouvera elle l'apprendra et elle
mettra sa place une jolie pièce de
monnaie tout brillant oui mais à
condition qu'on ne suce pas son pouce
car c'est très vilain de sucer son push
up
les petits enfants le savent bien et moi
je ne sus ça mais mon pouce machine
je suis jamais mon pouce ouais mais toi
t'as pas mal au dos et puis toi tu m'a
toujours aidé à donner moi d'entendre
des draps les wallons les enfants al
allons les enfants on va cacher cette
petite dans là tu mises petit louis
tous
[Musique]
orvoine noces le joli 7 dandine où est
ce qu'on va la cacher ici ou là
oui la petite souris et le rappeur n est
pas grave et s'aggravent les petites
souris s'aggrave je vous le dis sur la
mettais dans les fleurs non les enfants
confiés là moi je connais une bonne
cachette je m'en occupe
wallace of holy les enfants
[Musique]
petit oui tu me suces plutôt pouces 1 et
3 mirabel
tu ne mets plus les doigts d'en tourner
un c'est promis bon tu oublies pas
madame non soit tranquille petit louis
je m'en occupe
au revoir les enfants à demain
[Musique]
source peut être bavard à te voilà quand
même lambin mais qu'est ce que tu
fabriques nounours la note non la la ce
mieux le patron j'ai caché là dans de
petits louis
j'espère que la petite souris la
trouvera ah oui alors ne faisons pas de
bruit pour ne pas lui faire peur en
route nounours
bonne nuit les enfants c'est debout rêve
à demeure à demain
[Musique]
e
[Rires]
[Musique]
en
bonsoir mes petits et grands amis est-ce
que mais qu'est ce que tu fais grosse
chute patron chute je regarde si la
petite souris est passé ah oui c'est
vrai je me rappelle est ce que tu trouve
quelque chose je ne vois rien haha
voila voila patron ou le joli regard d
une pièce en vrai argent
c'est magnifique j'ai bien l'impression
que p'tit louis va être très content je
pense bien europe
je veux lui portait bompas pauvres oui
oui mais dépêche toi au point patron
propos poro
voilà la petite souris mini ville
d'hautmont allons deviner dans quel
patins passelac celle là c'est
maintenant du don c'était un mois la
danse de mado à moi je vais vrai c'était
là dedans at il oui est ce que la petite
souris à apporter c'est pour petit louis
ouais moi je crois que c'est dans celle
à
[Musique]
o o calmerait 11 que les gentils cette
petite souris noire on dit si tu la
rencontre tu lui diras bien merci de ma
part elle est vrai - cette pierre way
[Musique]
tout tombe argent j'avais dans ma
tirelire
excellente idée oh la belle truie tu
sais elle est presque plein ou à temps
voilà
jimmy la pièce mais c'est vrai il y a
beaucoup de sous là dedans tu retires
tirelire heures il a mis ses sabots
manger des abricots brille le chat de
janot qui joue du pipeau
il s'est mis sur la tête il a fait la
pire at il à pousser la brouette il
accueillit témoins des tirs qui retire
lire ça rires tu retires tirlo dodo a
rien dedans
[Musique]
borg vite le cher petit garnement
là c'est un la lumière
à demain un gamin de nous et du persil à
la petite souris non aux bonnes minutes
qui lui font ni mirabel
que
bonsoir petit louis bonsoir petite
mirabelle
bonsoir les petits enfants si vous êtes
bien sage
demain nous ferons ensemble un très joli
jeu et vous aussi vous jouerez avec nous
on opte patron il ne faut pas que
j'oublie de dire merci à la petite
souris
si nous la rencontrons dans le ciel nous
le lui dirons sans faute en route mon
vieux nounours bonne nuit les enfants à
demain à demain
[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonsoir les petits amis
aujourd'hui nous allons tous jouer
ensemble avec mirabel petit louis et
gros ours et vous allez jouer avec nous
pouvons au moins je suis bien content je
vais jouer avec les petits enfants à
cache cache
je descends patron et europe
[Musique]
[Rires]
c'est un jeu très facile écoutez bien
petit louis et mirabel vont se cacher
dans leur maison pendant qu'ils se
cachent
vous mettrez vos mains devant les yeux
pour ne pas voir où il se cache et quand
ils diront ça y est vous aiderez gros
ours à les trouver et les chercherait
avec lui ou se sont-ils gâcher ces deux
petits brigands
voyons voyons l'homme que vous voyons
voir sous la table non à à la non dans
la cheminée
coucou milliards
le maire ou son qu'il a à bon voyons
voir dans la chambre et non la fin mais
non émis sans fin dilou cou un foulard
et ville derrière les bêtes je n'y avais
pas pensé petit coq je bous c'est la
prochaine fête il ne devra pas caresser
vous vite on va voir ça on les trouvera
bien des spas à moi je vais les trouver
tout de suite
mais où sont ils à eux j'ai eu une idée
ils sont sûrement dans l'armoire à
hasnon et n'y sont pas mais où sont-ils
bon lolo haut et me donne chauveau alors
les enfants
vous savez où sont cachés mirabel et
petit louis vous avez trouvé
oui c'est très bien mais gros ours lui
n'a pas encore trouvé
nous allons l'aider un petit peu oh oui
merci patron mais qu'il a fait venir à
bâle et p'tit louis est de l'autre côté
et hausse
il est tombé ce que je suis fort quand
même
la dernière fois et j'irai dormir car je
suis fatigué
[Musique]
un voyage au point zéro et ils sont pas
là mais mais où sont-ils à mai à une
nuit ne sont pas sous le lit au fond les
coquins il était dedans on le lit c'est
une très bonne idée car il est tard cet
indice est mormon qui sait qu'ils jouent
très bien cache cache
ah bon bonne nuit des enfants dormaient
vite là
j'éteins la lumière
[Musique]
ni mirabel elle est quand même un peu
bêta 90
oui
[Musique]
alors les enfants vous avez bien joué à
cache-cache
moi je me suis bien amusé petit louis et
mirabel se sont très bien caché et ce
pauvre gros ours a eu beaucoup de mal
pour les trouver
oui patron c'est vrai je ne suis pas
très doué pour ce je suis un peu bête
alors en route
venus est enfin faite de doux rêves
à demain 1 demain les enfants
[Musique]
oh
quel silence mirabel et p'tit louis ont
l'air très sage ce soir où ils dorment
déjà
ou alors ils sont vraiment très absorbé
par un travail où ils me prépare une
nouvelle blague rue mais rose ours tu
adores savons pas toujours patron pas
toujours europe et courage nous
mon petit doigt me dit que ce soir ils
vont être très gentil ou un peu votre
pompe hop hop hop hop hop hop hop hop
pur porc au portant pour papoter propre
apport aux chats ils achètent flou
s'échappe au fond tu crois bon je trouve
un peu lourd à tort qu'il use les bouge
pas ne bouge pas
[Musique]
à demain je crois qu'il vaut mieux que
je revienne demain non je crois qu'il
est très tard il vaut mieux que je m'en
aille
tu voir aux us c'est un très beau
chapeau pour maman pour lui offrir
dimanche pour sa fête des marins il a
beaucoup de sites a dit oui comme m et
celle ci au bas du dos alors ben non ça
suffit comme ça fait japon tout seul
voyons les enfants raison de tous ces
géants vont pas au roi lion
oui aux no
par pitié would you do sul où le jeune
allemand
pour vos os aux yeux non non je crois
qu'il est très bien comme ça chapeau
c'est vrai oui il est très réussie ce
soit pour elle va être très content de
votre banque ou un celi ravages qui lui
donne ses jeunes pour moi je donne autre
chose qu'un cadeau ouais avec les sous
de matières les chevaliers acheter
quelque chose de très bons c'est très
gentil ça mais quoi peut-être un collier
avec un diamant
oui ou alors quelque chose dont elle a
besoin dans la maison et qui lui manque
après si c'est pas beau mouvement bien
les acheter des pantoufles à goethe une
excellente idée
toi toi nous nous qu'est-ce que tu
l'achète à ta maman
moi je vais lui acheter un joli car mais
pourquoi faire un joli carnet de bridge
oui elle joue au bridge avec ses habits
c'est une championne
[Musique]
voilà patron j'arrive à l'on dormait
vite les enfants
la nuit porte conseil
la gt1 la lumière est belle elle est
marrante la maman de gros offre enfin
oui elle shoebridge venait-il clientèle
vous aussi les petits enfants allez vite
vous coucher embrassez vos parents et
surtout n'oubliez pas dimanche de
souhaiter bonne fête à votre maman
car dimanche ce sera la fête de toutes
les mamans du monde europe la wii
et moi je vais vite lui acheter mon
cadeau et écrire à ma maman c'est très
bien ça ne nous fait un bon fils au
revoir les enfants
bonne nuit bonne nuit
oh
[Musique]
en
ouf quinze journées bonsoir les enfants
je suis sûr que vous avez été très
gentils aujourd'hui et que vous vous
êtes bien amusé où êtes vous allé à la
campagne au jardin ou ou et nous sommes
allés à la campagne et grosos est très
fier il a rapporté une jolie colombes
tout blanc joue ou au ce pour la petite
bière abel et p'tit louis le plus haut
alors ne soyez pas trop longs monsieur
roseaux rouaix peut pas perdre elle se
rappelle me non c'est la mienne
bon allez c'est la tienne au jardin nous
sommes jeunes et ken et les bleus vous
au pouvoir a vu la meinau ciel est bleu
ciel à bord rapportent une surprise pour
les enfants sa jeunesse on est un pain
moi j'ai planté des fleurs j'ai c'est un
grand château dans salle et j'ai coupé
une heure puis on a toi en v même vos
souliers contre notre surprise nounours
fermer les yeux et compté jusqu'à 3
[Musique]
attention ce ailleurs à ce que c'est
beau mais c'est un grand péché non c'est
une petite colombe que j'ai rapporté de
la campagne pour la fête de votre maman
c'est une idée qui jouent au hockey
alors regrette contente
[Musique]
tessinois notre maman tous les soirs
quand on est couché condat sur vienne
waban aki elle nous donne des musées oui
c'est vrai tu crois que non ce que
toutes les mamans elles sont comme ça
bien sûr tous les soirs quand les petits
enfants dorment
elles viennent fermer les volets bordés
leur lit et leur donner un baiser
ma maman à moi elle le faisait chaque
soir nous en a souhaité bonne fête
aujourd'hui les dragons temps il a
pleuré on lui a fait du tac cadeau et on
vient donner de très belles fleurs avec
notre papa c'est très bien mes enfants
c'est très bien mais à présent il est
l'heure de faire dodo est encore une
toute petite minute
on va t'il un joli car convaincu pour la
tuilerie petite maman voici des fleurs
avec notre coeur
comme cette maman bonne fête maman
bonne nuit les petits
à demain vonews dans bien des mirabelles
peu nui qui lui
[Musique]
man
bonne fête à toutes les mamans
bonne fête bob fait bonne nuit des
enfants continuer à être bien sage et à
être toujours très gentil avec votre
maman alors nounours en route
à demain à demain
[Musique]
vous
en
[Musique]
bonsoir les petits enfants gros ours et
moi nous sommes bien contents et vos
mamans aussi vous leur avez souhaité
hier une très belle fête et ça leur a
fait très plaisir vous savez au oui ce
joli l'a fait débat ben nounours va voir
si petit louis et mirabel sont bientôt
prêt à se mettre au lit j'y fonce patron
europe et revient vite me car nous
devons encore allez voir beaucoup
d'autres petits enfants ou un patron au
pow pow pow pow pow pow wow pour pop en
propre apport aux caves et fabriques à
vii souk
moi je crois bien que les colombes ça
mange des graines mais il ya une petite
colonne jours
mais enfin gentil a dit il c'est que
vous vous maman est à vraiment content
elle a dit que les colons c'est très
joli et excité magnifique surprise et
qu'on devait faire baisser de sa parole
c'est trop les enfants souhaitent trop
tu veux inviter à manger les colons une
pâte souple
je crois qu'il vaut mieux lui donner des
graines tu vois bien mirabel oui maman à
dire il faut aussi lui donner
moi je vais l'api sélective mais non on
va lui trouver un bon nom bien bas m on
va le lui trouver dans le dictionnaire
qui d'un génie qui nous voyons tyloo et
un dictionnaire c'est un livre où il y à
tous les maux et tous les noms ouais
voyons voir ou petit lion va voir là
ouh là bonjour les bouchons sur la
cheminée
bien sûr bien sûr que je suis étourdi
pas en voilà un
colombes il faut chercher à a cessé
voyons à b c'est coco coco colo à voilà
voilà
colombe banlieue de paris s'est pas noyé
quand l'on baye laye dès maintenant
quand l'on billes bris ta nick stokes
[Musique]
plus tôt
moi je trouve que petite colombe sait
gérer alors que l'on bat mais oui une
colombe à c'est très bien et bien
collombat nous te disons bonne nuit car
il est à peine 8 hollande a vite connu
une embauche
allez va vite rejoindre l'iss non je
couche touchait voisine pour voir mes
grands enfants à demain beaune et nuits
collombat
on
[Musique]
m
et vous aussi mes petits amis faites
comme petit louis et mirabel et comme
collombat allez vite vous couchez
embrasser bien fort vos parents vos
plats te voilà nounours en route car
nous sommes un peu en retard ce soir là
voilà papon bonne nuit les enfants à
demain demain
[Musique]
e
on
[Musique]
bonsoir les enfants boers soir petit
louis et mirabel ont l'air très sage ce
soir j'espère que collombat a bien mangé
ces graines
et vous votre soupe et toi gros morceau
mois patron je mange toujours bien basse
ou c'est très bien ça nours je descends
voir mes petits amis pompe à pompe hop
hop hop hop à colombes un choix sage
non j'ai encore un peu de salade toutes
petites feuilles mademoiselle collombat
bonjour vous jamais los pinos tu viens
faire une ronde avec nous bien sûr les
amphores chicane mais nous ce n'était
pas ma vendre des rouge et bleu et
blanche
j'en ai tant dans mon panier qu'elle
roule dans l'escalier trois ou quatre
pour un sou mademoiselle retournez vous
vous aussi mes petits amis chanter avec
nous 1 2 3 j'ai des pommes à vendre des
musées de bios je me tendant montagneux
de leur rôle dans l'escalier trois ou
quatre pour un sou mademoiselle retour
et vous j'étais pas mal à vendre des
rouges était blanche
j'en et un dans mon panier qu'elle roule
dans l'escalier trois ou quatre pour un
sou
manuel dos est avec nous je dépends à
vendre et vous j'ai des mages jeu
mettant dans mon panier qu'elle roule
dans l'escalier trois ou quatre pour un
sou non elle dormait avec non je ne peux
pas encore eu lie ce matin we were
patron l'aurez envoyée
il me surveille je vous le promets des
enfants mais une autre fois la jette à
la lumière en dormez-vous vite car ça
plombe haoussa bonsoir les enfants
l'ennemi numéro vert
[Musique]
venus est petit louis bonne une petite
mirabelle
bonne nuit à tous les enfants allez vite
vous coucher et faites de beaux rêves
nous reviendrons vous voir demain si
vous êtes bien sage en route une ourse
bonne nuit à demain à demain
[Musique]
e
bonsoir les amis bonsoir gloomy avez
vous été sage aujourd'hui
avez vous était sage aujourd'hui et
mehdi dans gros ours
tu as fini de répéter toutes mes paroles
comme un perroquet comme un perroquet ou
au pardon patron je pense gross a
apporté un jeu de cartes pour faire une
partie avec p'tit louis et mirabel on va
jouer au bridge patron ou à la belote
c'est une excellente idée et ils
aimeront beaucoup ça j'en ai bien la
pression mais tu ne dois pas tricher
nounours cela contribue foison patron je
ne triche jamais vous le savez bien
enfin on verra heureux au haut up la
folie ne triche pas une rue patron pom
pom pom pom poms poms poms poms poms
poms poms pas pour autant on peut entrer
une passion vont recevoir les enfants
joly dites moi
avez vous été sages comme des images
bon et bien on va jouer ensemble mais à
sept moteurs aux gendarmes ils veulent
et non les enfants pas de ces jeux barba
on va jouer aux cartes on va jouer au
bridge au bridge comme ta maman au nom
alors je te jure pour les oui bon et
bien on va jouer à la belote se pose
pour nous on pourrait peut-être j'ai pas
moins faire un rami ou il canasta bon
alors que diriez-vous d'une petite
partie de battage c'est une bonne idée
on est d'accord moment qu'ils veulent
mais car moi bon moi c'est moi qui l'ait
[Musique]
mais qu'est ce que tu fais le nom si tu
regarde quelqu'un qui triche gros yeux
revoit nouveau ne regarde pas mes cartes
là là ça y est à toi tu commences est-il
oui disent rouge danois à bois à moi en
place de piquets serrés moitié gagné non
alors je continue
2 cette fois tu vas perdre
[Musique]
bataille
on a ce talent voilà quatre essieux
rabais pas vrai c'est pas vrai c'est toi
qui as triché petit louis oui mais c'est
mal et gagner bande de tricheurs
youpi voilà patron j'arrive lui patron
c'est moi qui ai commencé à tricher on
lit les enfants une autre fois on jouera
au bridge c'est un jeu beaucoup plus
sain du tri sera plus à nos moeurs
c'est promis les enfants je ne tricherai
plus là j'éteins la lumière à demain les
enfants
ulysse va me passionne c'est savon on
voit contré chef d'un émirat val banide
qui lui
[Musique]
très vilain de tricher au jeu je ne suis
pas content du tout gross dont ça a été
très vilain à vous voilà monsieur le
tricheur
vous pouvez être fiers de vous c'est du
propre
je ne le ferai plus pas trop je vous le
promets pour de punir
tu ne mangeras pas de miel demain ni
après-demain bien pas trop connu les
enfants embrasser vite vos parents est
allé sagement vous coucher demain je
vous raconterai une belle histoire
bonne nuit bonne nuit
[Musique]
on
bonsoir mes chers petits amis bonsoir
mirabel et son frère petit louis sont de
plus en plus sage petit louis ne suce
plus on pousse et mirabel ne n'ai plus
les doigts dans son nez leur maman est
bien content rosso oui et moi aussi je
suis bien content car il me l'avait
promis
j'espère que vous aussi les petits
enfants vous suivez leurs bons exemples
ce soir je vais vous raconter une belle
histoire et en plaçant toujours quiz
d'accord gros ours tu descends leur
montrer le livre d'image et moi je leur
raconte l'histoire très bien patron je
prends le livre et des peuples à bompas
propos pour déçoit pas trop lent
nounours ouais ouais propos
en fait à sa fin
[Musique]
bonsoir les petits diables mais pourquoi
ne ferait on pas plutôt une partie de
bruit joe ou bien un petit poker encore
pas trop j'avais oublié non les enfants
ulysse m'a interdit de jouer aux cartes
parce qu'un jeu triste j'ai bien des
enfants
je vais essayer de faire comme vous mais
je vous ai apporté un beau livre d'image
que je vais vous montrer et que ulysse
va vous raconter chic alors
asseyons-nous là on est bien installé
oui bon c'est l'histoire de la belette
qui avait perdu ses lunettes
quel beau livre raconte l'histoire vous
pas trop madame belette qui était fort
distraite par un beau jour de printemps
avait perdu ses lunettes
elle ne voyait plus rien la pauvrette
car il était très myope et à se cogner
par tous ces détritus les enfants
écouter la suite
[Musique]
elle marche a longtemps et arriva enfin
devant une maison qu'elle cru être la
sienne en boulettes distraite
elle avait bien sûr oublier ses clés et
elle fera pas donc à la porte
toc toc toc mais ça ne va pas d'âme
belette ma parole mais mais tu vois de
travers
qu'as tu fait de tes lunettes c'était
monsieur d'escargots en personne car
dame belette bien entendu s'était trompé
de maison les enfants elle m'intéresse
voir à cette histoire je cherche ma
maison qu'on perd escargots je cherche
ma maison viendront avec moi d'un meuble
est répondit l'escargot qui était un
petit coquin vient nous allons la
chercher ensemble et il emmena notre
belette distraite à travers chants très
loin et elle était bien fatiguée elle se
cognait tout le temps aux fleurs aux
cailloux et se perdaient au milieu des
grands champs de blé et elle n'arrêtait
pas de répéter mais où sont dont mes
lunettes ou son nom mes lunettes et
compère escargot qui s'amusaient comme
un petit fou des malheurs de notre
pauvre belette rien sous sa coquille
ils arrivèrent alors au milieu d'un
grand champlain de coquelicots et il
entendit un bruit terrible biblique
ce n'est pas bon on ne peut pas manger
ça
c'est trop dur ça fait mal au bec ils
s'approchèrent et découvrir un joli
petit nid plein de bébés fauve est pas
content du tout leur maman leur avait
porté à manger quelque chose de très dur
et devinez ce que c'était c'étaient les
lunettes de dames belette ou moi j'ai
trouvé ça et j'ai cru que c'était bon à
manger dit la maman fauvettes mais en
effet vous avez raison c'est trop dur et
à plat et les jeta hors du nid et l
atterrir vous savez où sur le nez de
dames belette lunettes
mes lunettes merci gentil fauvettes et
notre belette danser et sauter de joie
elle était si contente qu'elle invite à
tous ses amis à dîner
sans oublier ce qu'aucun d'escargots et
ce fut une grande fête
il y eut des graines pour les petits
oiseaux et même une feuille de salade
pour ce farceur d'escargots cette
histoire merci de nous
la silice allons les bambins au lit il
est tendre qui ne nous attaquent à delhi
oui j'oubliais les enfants merci n'y a
ni non ça demain voir les enfants à
demain
[Musique]
et
non
[Musique]
louis monier mirabel
bonne nuit tous les enfants aller vite
au dodo nous reviendrons vous voir
demain en vaut deux compagnons en route
patron bonne nuit
bonne nuit
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]